this is a production of Cornell
University
and it's hard enough to follow alan
Armitage but now I have to follow that
intro apologies everybody this was cool
thing that showed up on the web all
right they told me I was supposed to
talk about edible diseases well this is
edible flowers for starters there's our
cupcakes okay and I'm going to enjoy
taking you through some of the the
stories about edibles because that's
what I'm supposed to talk about it and
we'll see if all these little wires
start working oh cool okay because Betsy
and Neil who were putting the program
together asked me to talk about edibles
and I work on diseases so I'm going to
talk to you about edible diseases at
least at the beginning here for a little
while so here you have the first edible
disease some of you may have eaten this
one this is something we used to call
the sulfur shelf and it's bright orange
so my husband Robert will not touch it
because he says food should not be that
orange but it is quite delicious and
it's a very weak parasite of trees more
of a saprophyte but it can cause a week
rot of the tree and you'll get sort of a
brown heart rhyme in a tree so we can
never avenge on this particular disease
by eating it so it's an edible disease
all right here's another one if you love
your turf you'll think of this as fairy
ring and that's a disease right you know
a fairy ring you might think of those as
places toads sit but it's better to
think about fairies dancing and however
you get close enough you can realize
that's also an edible disease because
you have chanterelles they're perfectly
edible perfectly wonderful and then
finally one that all the people who
watch trees perish in their landscapes
get to know our malaria melia which
causes our malaria root rot or the
shoestring root rot has an alter ego
it's known as the honey fungus because
it creates a mushroom when it fruits up
from the sick roots and we can eat that
mushroom it's a very delicious mushroom
with a Swedish kind of flavor to it so
here again you've got a plant disease
that is truly inedible but just one last
one because it's still before lunch you
think you can handle this we don't
always think of corn isn't ornamental
but there is an ornamental popcorn now
and back in
many years we've had a edible disease of
the corn plant how many of you ever seen
corn smut it's sort of a a very
interesting thing that will take the
kernels of the corn and turn them into
these big swollen white balls and those
balls are later on filled with white
smut spores because this is a smut
fungus and the amazing thing is that the
Mexicans in particular really value this
as an extremely valuable foodstuff and
when I got to travel down to Mexico
years ago we were able to get tacos that
had huitlacoche in there and it was very
exciting tastes like spinach a lot of a
lot of hype for something it tasted like
spinach but it's it's one of the
diseases we can have revenge on by
consuming them unfortunately this
doesn't apply to too many of our
ornamental plants and diseases are just
a pain but oh I wanted to know there is
a possibility for a little revenge on
the diseases that are ornamental these
the crops that I find growers getting
most aware of now Alan was absolutely
right when people say vegetables they
mean tomatoes and I think the greenhouse
growers who used to grow flowers all
understand that they're now growing
flowers + tomatoes if they're not
touching anything else and the other
thing they figured out quite a while ago
was that that also included herbs so
you'll see on my less basil and rosemary
because they are grown so widely by the
folks who used to think in terms of
geraniums and poinsettias and also
tomatoes peppers kale and the cucumber
and squash group the Q curve it's so
these are the topics I'll touch on today
and when we're doing a little disease
walk about this afternoon I can talk
about some of the other horrible
dreadful diseases like the ones that are
attacking begonias and attacking
impatience and what have you when it
comes to the diseases of edible crops
below ground it's pretty much all the
same as what you know the same fungi
things like Pythium and rhizoctonia and
phytophthora are going to be able to go
after the roots of your edibles just
like they go can go after the roots of
your flower crops the unfortunate thing
is you have a lot fewer things you can
do about them you can't put by the ban
rot to treat your edible play
so you need to be an even better grower
when you're producing the vegetables
because you need to have extremely good
sanitation so that you can pull these
crops through without using things
illegally and unsafely on the edible
crops here's another example
phytophthora on lavender a very common
disease problem because lavenders want
to be in a nice Mediterranean climate
and you put them in the greenhouse and
water them along with everything else
they get too wet so yes one problem is
the sanitation because the fight toppler
it can be there and pounce on them but
the more wetness you have the more
horrendous and epidemic you're going to
have in the greenhouse so let's start
out with basil I think this is the one
that drives the most people the craziest
here's a long list of the things that
can go wrong with basil will focus
mostly on the downy mildew because
that's certainly the ultimate problem on
that but you have an assortment of
difficulties for that crop potentially
you can have viruses like the insp and
the tswv up at the top you can have
various fungal problems like in track
noses or cercospora leaf spot you can
even have a systemic disease of fusarium
wilt disease root rot problems and then
in other parts of the world that even
have rusts and powdery mildews so if we
start importing basil from other places
we may get those diseases on top of the
ones that you have listed here upper
left there you'll see some modeling on
the foliage that's the look of tswv or I
nsv the two viruses are carried by
thrips that can affect basil I see this
a lot because the basil tends to be
grown right there along with the cutting
produced flowers and you're cutting
produce flowers are one of the ways
you're going to get tswv or I nsv going
in the greenhouse thrips can move it
from one plant to the next basil is one
of the susceptible plants so if that's
one of the many things you need to
protect your basil against and then at
the right is an image that I took up
here in Ithaca when I was visiting Neil
and I were doing some experiments with
basil and we got the fusarium wilt we
weren't expecting it but unfortunately
that particular disease is spread by
seed so again geez sometimes I think
these grafting ideas are good because if
we can get away from everyone working
with see the
has sort of unknown cleanliness we might
be able to get away from the possibility
of a fuse areum will obviously it can
kill the plan once in a rare while we'll
see an interac no sorcerer cost per leaf
spot when you see here and this is the
big one all right and this lighting it's
not too obvious but there's a little
yellowing on that basil and when you
turn the leap over you see a little dirt
on the underside it looks a little furry
and over the telephone people have told
me that looks like botrytis but they'll
mention that the leaf is still green so
that's the look of down emailed you
starting out on the underside of your
basil leaves we found last year when we
did some experiments with a slow release
fertilizer combined with a fungicide
that the more you fertilize the plant
the more impressive you can make the
down emailed you look you can get large
yellow window panes when the downy
mildew is going after basil under a high
fertilized situation and this is more
the field look okay a farmer initially
back when this was not a well-known
disease would look at this and think he
needed to add more nitrogen but it
certainly changed now to where people
are really watching all the time for
down yelled you to come in this is a
contrast here between the downy mildew
on the basil and the downy mildew on
coleus initially we thought they might
be the same organism but it turns that
they really aren't the same they look
the same under the microscope when they
make their spores the spores are pretty
much the same but this is a lesson
nitpicking here just for those of you
who think people at University shall
little geeky and worry about details the
way we can tell them apart is because
one of them is sort of a 1.2 four
lengths to breath ratio versus a 1.2
nine lengths to breath ratio and they
call this broadly ellipsoidal versus egg
shape now is that picayune or what so
they're really close in size but you can
measure the difference if you have a lot
of time and then even better yet now we
have DNA analysis where we can really
compare one organism to the other and
there are a lot of base pairs different
in those two organisms so you end up
with the coleus not really being named
yet and the the disease on the basil is
Perenara Bell berea so basically this is
important to you as a garden center or
whatever because you don't have to worry
about the downy mildew on your coleus
moving in
your basil and that's important because
we do have a coleus problem with a very
similar downy mildew getting back to the
basil this story is not terribly long
because we haven't had this disease in
the United States or in north america
until 2007 so it is new to us that's why
basil used to grow so well and now it
doesn't it's a new disease it's one of
these things that we run into because we
have global distribution of plants now
and it's been quite a problem since it
showed up in Florida in 2007 it was
about probably only about a year after
we started having trouble with the
coleus you get that furry growth of the
spores on the underside of the leaf and
this is what it looks like under the
microscope make sort of a little tree
and you get these little footballs
hanging from the ends of the branches
that you can only see with the
microscope the curious thing about this
disease is that it actually was known
first in Africa it was seen in a ganda
in 1933 and then people were not paying
a whole lot of attention to it but there
was an outbreak in 1994 where it started
moving into Switzerland and then started
moving around Europe and it wasn't too
long after that that we saw it in
Florida so now it's a worldwide problem
all the little yellow spots show you
places where this disease has has
appeared now pretty much all the places
where anyone would ever grow basil one
curious slant is that it shows up in
microgreens also talk about a way to
devastate a crop there's a lot of yellow
modeling that shows when you have better
lighting on the image here at the left
and you can see the dirtiness on the
underside of the the cotyledons of those
little basil seedlings if you were a
microgreen producer you just have to
hang it up when you see this you're not
going to get your crop through it's
impossible and then you can't really get
the other crops through that might be
just behind it you have to really clear
everything out and start over again once
the spores have died there really a
devastating problem and it's quite
obvious in this situation that you have
a seed boring problem okay it definitely
can get started from the seed so no
matter how early your plant has started
you might have a problem with it and
then a few years ago we had a company
that got interested in doing grafted
basil but
without proper respect for the downy
mildew and it became a problem in some
of the production these were great
plants how much did you sell these for
mark you didn't have those you're smart
and they were selling for you know
somewhere between 25 and fifty dollars
apiece this was in Greenwich Connecticut
I knew it was $25 or so a lot to sell a
basil plant for mind you but they did
also in some cases come with some downy
mildew so there's plants were complete
lawsuits so you paid a lot for your
initial grafted plant and then you could
not sell it later on so as we get into
these special new crops we really all
look for their Achilles heels and plan
for them meg McGrath who works in
vegetable plant pathology with me down
at the Long Island horticultural
research and Extension Center had put
together some interesting data
collection on the subject of basil downy
mildew by using the web to get people to
tell her what was happening where and so
she's got some interesting stats on it
we've known about the disease in New
York and Florida for now it'd be more
like 10 years because the slides a few
years old but you can see New York's
always at the epicenter of everything
and then here's some more look up here
74 reports New York up till 2014 that's
because we were going around given talks
about it and everybody was saying oh
yeah we've got it it's not really worse
in New York but don't for one moment
think that we don't have to deal with it
it's not a southern person's disease
it's it's a disease of the entire
industry and it's certainly disease of
the green s industry as well as the
outdoor industry so you as greenhouse
industry people want to make sure you're
not sharing that disease with farmers
and your vicinity any earlier than
they're going to have to cope with it
for other reasons there also is a real
global aspect to this it's it's showing
up in places you know Argentina is
having to fight basil downy mildew now
what the important effort on this is the
same one that we're going to see with
other diseases we've looked into the
types of basil and how susceptible they
are and there are now at least two major
breeding programs run at Rutgers and one
at the University of Florida where
they're looking to get us something
that's not as susceptible as the
standard awesome imbecilic amor however
that should be pronounced because your
basic Genovese basil is
highly susceptible to down emailed you
so they notice that if you had the
American own species that you would have
a much less highly susceptible plant so
their efforts to breed those genetics
into the plant that we're selling that
will ultimately become pesto or or a
caprese salad or what have you and there
has been some success along those lines
but we're not quite there yet at this
point some of you've probably grown the
eleonora which is a sweet basil that has
a little bit of resistance in it it's
not that it won't get the disease but it
will get a little slower so that's on
the market at the moment probably one of
the better options there is a reason why
we're finding the seed transmission and
that's because the downy mildew makes a
special kind of spore that allows it to
reside within the seed make it through
that winter period and we know it's
there we could treat the seed to get rid
of the problem except for the fact that
basil seeds are really goopy when you
get them in hot water so there's only
one company in Europe at this point that
is treating seed to get rid of the downy
mildew and that they're using a steam
treatment method that somehow avoids the
glop eNOS so if you can get some of that
European heat-treated material out of
Germany then you'll be better off and
gloppy is not a botanical term but it
works great who didn't understand that
term will define worry and the the
amount of basil that gets basil seed
that has the problem is pretty high and
these are European figures here when
they did one survey they found that it
was virtually and everything and that
when you planted it out a pretty high
percentage of those seed we're going to
see lots we're going to give them
disease so if you've been feeling like
it's just you and there's something
really torturing you it's not there's
their seed contamination and it's very
hard to avoid it yes when the plant is
contaminated when that plan is being
grown as a seed parent there is
infection of the entire plant
systemically it's a systemic disease so
it can come from inside it survives
along the plants survive long enough to
produce seed right it would have to be a
later infection for just that reason
yeah
and then and then it gets inside and
stays inside as OS force yeah it's it's
too bad isn't yeah okay there's one
really interesting little thing which
I'm hoping this industry can be clever
enough to capitalize on some of the
research and Israel has shown that light
really impedes the spore production of
the basil down emailed you it doesn't
stop infection I wish it stopped
infection that would be even better but
if you can keep the leaves directly in
contact with light you can stop spore
production that's really stops your
epidemic or at least slows it down a
great deal so they've done things they
produce their basil in fields at and in
the night they're just stringing lights
over them and providing light and
they're getting something like 18 days a
product protection on a plant the
thicker the canopy gets the more you
have parts of the plant that aren't
directly exposed to the light so your
effectiveness goes down but if you're
growing something like microgreens you
could really make use of light and this
will illustrate the idea for you there's
blue things on the left or test tube
caps and after these plants were sprayed
with sporangia of downy mildew the test
tube camps were placed on and then given
a little time all right and the only
places where you got spore production
three days later we're over at the right
where you see the darkness the places
where the test tubes kept the light off
okay really nifty and you know you can
you can use this to your betterment
whether you can make it go away
completely that way I would doubt but
you could probably make things better by
supplying light during your basal
production so these are the kind of
things you want to think about if you're
trying to get basil through without
downy mildew if you can buy clean seed
that has been treated with steam try to
go with your less susceptible varieties
and this will be getting better all the
time I think in four years or so we'll
have plants we can buy that won't get
this disease anymore check if you're
bringing in transplants look them over
really hard if you see any yellow me on
the leaves put them in a plastic bag
with a wet paper towel overnight and see
if they're furry underneath the next
morning you can look for the downy
mildew do a lot of scouting and you can
apply treatments and you do need to
apply treatments the phosphorus acids
rivas and ran manner
options for chemical control in the
greenhouse keep your humidity down play
with the light experimentally see what
you can do with that and if you have a
problem just get rid of everything and
then start over again that's really all
you can do we're also suggesting that
you try to grow basil earlier in the
season because the further you get into
summer the more likely you are to run
into some sort of inoculum coming in
from outside the greenhouse getting into
your production so early your production
is safer than later production but even
early production you might get in
trouble because of seed transmission not
all seeds contaminated but some is um
okay I mentioned these here your
products that are phosphorous assets on
the top row just some examples of ones
that are labeled for use on basil things
like k fight or phosphate or Rambert
they're in a group that's called the
frack group 33 that have phosphorous
acid as their active ingredient and
revis and ran man are the things people
would be using on outdoor crops but they
have labels that do not prohibit using
green ounces so that's an option for you
too it's perfectly okay to use that
group 33 over and over again if you want
to it's not prone to resistance
development and most growers are doing
that but it's only going to last for
about a week okay next plant rosemary um
it's a plant without a lot of problems
but it has a few and my job is to tell
you what they are primarily you're going
to have to battle powdery mildew on
rosemary and this last year was a bad
year for powdery mildew on rosemary it
was in the trade for whatever reason so
many of you discovered it for the first
time and we're wondering why your plants
look white when you were supposed to
look green they're supposed to have a
little bit of a waxy bloom but not that
much waxy bloom you get this kind of a
look okay looks like it's been dusted
ideally you should be scouting for this
and the minute you see any of it really
go right in there and start a program
where you're working with something that
will stop powder and noting because once
it begins in the greenhouse you have
high enough humidity that it's going to
keep happening in the greenhouse all
season long this is a similar-looking
plant but it looks worse this particular
case is down email to you and I've only
seen this once but because we're having
such a bad time with down emailed users
on so many other plants I just want to
warn you about it so if you see
something that
is making the plants look really unhappy
but you don't see the powdery mildew on
keep this in mind is one possible
explanation you can just throw it away
if you see it it's hopefully not going
to be a big deal for powdery mildew
maintenance which is a more standard
thing this experiment might give you a
few ideas we work with ultra fine oil
now you would probably be using some oil
X and we work with Mills stop and cease
and we tried them alone and you can see
that the mills stop and the oil work
most powerfully to reduce the powdery
mildew we also tried alternations which
is much more of what you would be likely
to do in the greenhouse and by using
three of those ingredients together or
alternating two of them it worked really
easily so probably mill stop with one of
the others would be your best program to
use to keep your powder email you
managed on rosemary and the greenness
tomato diseases okay this is the one
vegetable and this is the main one I
really want to speak to you about
because homeowners all want this but not
all of you are used to growing
vegetables you started out in the flower
industry in many cases so you don't know
the standard things that any tomato
grower would know and you need to know
these things the disease there that's at
the end of the list by top there infest
hands is a scary disease it brought us
all the Irish over from Ireland because
they were starving to death because of
the effects of that disease on the
potato crop and then somewhere along the
lines the organism learned to switch
over and also attack tomatoes so now we
have something that's a really serious
disease that we might end up harboring
in our greenhouse industry and we don't
want to be doing that and then there are
a few other things there that are every
day for a farmer that you might not know
about one of the ones you do know about
is this a couple years ago just your
season before this we had a real scare
about tmb tobacco mosaic virus on
between us and the greenhouse and if you
carry the crop all the way through you
might see symptoms like these where you
get a verra Gatien or modeling in the
flowers of the plant early season many
growers also saw strap-like leaves or
stunting or dead leaves because of the
effects of tmv on petunia that comes
from an error up at the source of your
cuttings and the company that had that
problem worked bent over backwards to
clean it all up and have a good year
this year and it worked so I'm glad to
see that extra sanitation will defend us
against this problem but many people did
learn that it was scary because they
learned that petunias could be a source
of trouble for tomatoes in particular
and it also has a huge host range the
biggest danger would be heirloom
tomatoes because they don't have any
natural resistance built into them so if
you're growing petunias particularly if
you're bringing them in as cuttings from
offshore I really try to keep your
tomatoes away from them that's one of
the smartest things you can do this is
the kind of thing you can do to a tomato
fruit it's not pretty you can do a lot
of other ugly things you might not even
get to fruit we learned that nonfat dry
milk is one of our most useful control
materials when you're dealing with tmv
and the green is so if you do find that
you have it respond with an excellent
sanitation disposal and a lot of use of
dried milk solution okay back to your
leaf spots one of the many things that
we have to worry about on tomatoes we've
seen this you know seven or eight times
this year down on Long Island it's a
pretty common disease on tomatoes you
probably all have it at home not easy to
tell which one is which but there are
three bacterial leaf problems that can
occur in tomatoes bacterial spots the
most common which is a xanthomonas
bacterium but there's also bacterial
canker and bacterial spec and there's a
fungal leaf spot that you're probably
not going to be able to tell the
difference from which is the one here at
the lower right that's a septoria leaf
spot it's also pretty common on tomato
to work against that the farmers have
learned to use treated seed I don't know
that you folks are always getting
treated see but maybe you want to look
into that because hot water treatment
will eliminate some of these problems
you can use copper and agri meissen type
fungicides on tomato and pepper in the
greenhouse but not necessarily on any of
your other crops because they're labeled
for specific vegetables you want to
reduce your leaf wetness and splashing
because that can move bacteria from
place to place and really inspect your
plants and throw away problems while
they're still small you may not want to
do a lot of treatment but just an
occasional copper maintenance spray may
help you stay I
of a big problem with this kind of leaf
spawning another spotter on tomato is
tomato spotted wilt virus you heard a
lot about this virus as ornamental
producers before you ever grew a tomato
but there's a reason why it's called
tomato spotted wilt it can make spots on
tomato alright and it looks a little
different each time just as it looks
different on each of your flower crops
it can look different on each tomato
cultivars that you might grow and it can
be ugly so it's another one of the
things you don't want to get into your
vegetable crops this virus isn't on seed
so if you can keep your cutting grown
crops and your thrips away from tomatoes
that you're producing from seed that'll
do a great deal of good to keeping
tensed up you be away from them you get
fruit symptoms as well as spots when you
have tswv in tomatoes and one of the
things that helps you identify it are
these blackish streaks that are down the
middle of the leaf there that's quite
typical of tswv on a tomato and then
really ugly things can happen to the
tomatoes your customers won't like TSW
be on their tomatoes keeping the flowers
and the vegetables apart would be great
for this it's not possible for some of
you but it's a goal alright I think it
will help our future production because
we don't like being in a situation where
we have for example a material that you
can spray on one plant but it's illegal
to spray on the one beside it it's not a
good situation to be in so I think
keeping things separate will really help
us in the future and definitely watching
them and knowing what the symptoms are
so that you can pick up on them just as
they're starting up and then finally the
late blight late bite will cause large
debt areas in the leaves and it can look
a lot like botrytis we work with a
grower a couple years ago who was
treating for botrytis because he thought
he had botrytis and his tomatoes because
he was a flower grower he knew botrytis
but he didn't know about late blight
which causes large lesions with maybe a
pale rim around them and then it can
also cause stem lesions hopefully you
can make out these are a little bit
frosty and that's because you get a lot
of the sporangia produced on the surface
it's almost like a down emailed you the
fight topler infestans that causes this
late blight disease is truly genetically
very similar to a downy mildew and it's
airborne so it can move great distances
and it's really a pernicious threat this
is kind of thing it does to a tomato all
right not a good thing all right and it
can do this to a tomato also not a good
thing we do know it can go to petunias
it's very rare that goes to petunias but
this is one of Margo bechtel slides who
got her PhD here at Cornell a number of
years ago she caused this particular
infection but this is a picture from a
box that was shipped into me sometime
that incubated on route got real fuzzy
on the way you really can occasionally
have that disease in petunia so watch
for that let me know if you see anything
remotely like it this is a picture from
the botrytis like late light infection
that occurred a couple of years ago we
still have no idea what the source was
and we're thinking it might have been
some solanaceous ornamental light of
Central America that was growing in the
same greenhouse we have no idea the
strain was tested here at Cornell and we
know it's not the standard strains this
is a listing that you don't need to pay
a whole lot of attention to other than
to see that the string called us 23 is
sensitive to methanol sim which is in
subdue max and that one affects potato
and tomato and it's the dominant one
that we've been seeing in New York for
the past several years good in some ways
bad and others and this is one of meg's
maps that gives you a sense if you
follow the dates of how the late blight
disease would ordinarily start down in
Florida and move its way up the coast
and get to us late which is why it's
called late blight but guess what our
greenhouse industry ships plants all
over creation so in 2009 there was
enough shipping of contaminated tomatoes
from the south that got all over the
Northeast and it was a really early
epidemic problem for all the farmers in
the Northeast so we don't want to be
part of that we need to inspect our
crops to make sure we're not moving late
blight around this repeats everything I
just said I think definitely watch for
this one it's not going to be common but
it's bad if you get it and I wanted to
give you some hope here there's
information now on some cultivars that
are resistant to late blight and as an
industry particularly if you're a garden
center you can really help people by
offering and promoting the late blight
resistant cultivars so here we're going
to have the same control at the right
hand side for each of these images now
fresh plus obviously is susceptible to
the disease it's blighted right over at
the left you see Mountain merit which
looks pretty good and up at the top it's
got a little notation there it tells you
it as two different genes for resistance
but if we go to Iron Lady nice name huh
looks good the mountain fresh plus of
course looks really dead and here you
have mountain magic which is probably
gotten the most promotion has anybody
sold mountain magic good it's good to
see the hands all right good good idea
and here we got Jasper Jespers a cherry
tomato and really very very good
resistance that's what the tomatoes look
like at the upper right that's Meg's
husband and Sandy menasha our vegetable
agent down to the right Jasper's are
really high performing cherry tomato
resistant to the late blight and this
information is all on the web meg has an
excellent website that you can get to
that's a vegetable md site that said
Cornell the resistance is coming from a
wild relative of the tomato this
selenium Pepin Ella folium is where
there's genes are coming from and thank
goodness for them because that will with
time breathe is out of this problem make
everything wonderful again I have a nap
too meg and I work together on one with
the plant pathology society that's
available it's the notes are in your
handout sheet if you look under either
plant health or tomato md with a space
between tomato and md it's not as pretty
sound zap I'm sorry it has all sick
plants in it I don't think there's a
single healthy plant in the entire app
but if you want to have one for
reference when you're talking to
gardeners at your garden center or you
have tomatoes at home it has 350 or so
pictures of sick tomatoes in it that's
pretty cool right yes
yes that's a very good question it's
very true unfortunately certain ones
that are selenium okay we'll definitely
Harbor late light the biggest Harbor is
however potato because you'll get potato
volunteers you know the next year it
doesn't over winter and tomato per se
but potato is a very bad carryover so if
you alternate between potato and tomato
and your fields and you have potatoes
coming up coming up among the tomatoes
the disease will come right along with
it and you know weed control doesn't
hurt either absolutely okay just a
couple things on pepper the ornamental
pepper is prone to bacterial leaf spots
and also the non ornamental pepper is
from to bacterial leaf spots so again
copper might be useful to you there
we've also seen I nsv on peppers and all
sorts of interesting different spots
pale spots brown spots the insp really
moves in on those and then even a zigzag
line you might see that symptom this
could only be caused by virus there's
nothing else that can give you that kind
of a pattern in a plant and one other
whole disease curiosity that you might
be aware of and might not the powdery
mildew we're used to seeing on verbenas
also goes to cucurbits so if you're
growing verbenas is flowers and also hey
new one this year we started having a
lot of trouble with caliber colas with
powdery mildew that's also the same one
so you can have movement from the curb
it back and forth to the verbena and
it's good to know those are good things
to keep apart and be aware of that if
you've seen pumpkins looking white in
the fall that's from powdery mildew it's
very damaging to the fruits and tends to
create sun-scorched when they've got the
powdery mildew but those spores can grow
and blow into the greenhouse if you were
thinking of keeping verbena over and
then you can keep the powdery mildew
over on the verbena and I wouldn't say
this except I've seen people do it so
they'll keep verbena in the back and
then they wonder why they're zucchini
you're looking funny the next spring
well this is why they manage to keep the
inoculum over and we will see the same
disease on petunias particularly in the
field in the at the end of the year
there is a lot of variation from one
verbena to the next and that problem has
gone way down the industry really got
rid of the cult
hours that were highly susceptible so I
don't think it's a common problem
anymore but maybe the caliber coma
problem is on the way up so watch them
and keep the powdery mildew under
control because you don't want to cause
the farmers in your area to have extra
trouble with early epidemics because
you're growing that same disease on your
flower crops bacterial things are
bothering air kale and ornamental
cabbage growers now and and the the
farmers know this disease you might not
if you're coming in from the ornamental
side of things here's an ornamental kale
with yellow wedges and the leaves
starting on the lower leaves and
climbing up the plant the disease is
called black rot and it's a xanthomonas
not the same one that goes to geraniums
it's just a cousin and its seed born aha
another problem and as the the kale got
more popular the past few years I think
it lowered the seed quality because
everybody was scrambling to get enough
seed so particularly the red boar
cultivar of kale has been a real problem
for our growers in recent years it is a
systemic disease so you can see in a
cross-section of the stem little black
areas where the vascular system is
infected and you can put under the
microscope and over at the right maybe
you can envision there's a pulsing out
of lots of little bacterial cells in
water from a cut vein really an easily
spread disease so it's good for you to
be aware of it so that you will be able
to recognize it and rogue out the plants
that have that problem and go on to grow
the rest with the help of some copper
sprays these things are all handleable
if you're not ignorant of them so just
being aware of what the problems are
that can affect your edible crops that
you're growing in the green s will help
you a great deal and hopefully
everything can just be hunky-dory in
your production I don't want to take any
questions just because of our time
situation because one should have a
break but thanks for your attention and
you'll all have a chance to ask me
questions this afternoon when we're
going around thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu